ん
今日は日本を保護るトップスパへ
は
g
[音楽]
りゅうたろうなお前が時スパイの貴方が張っているか場合ロ
なぜスパイがスパイをするのかその貴方が
情報収集ばれずにどこまで潜入するか潜入して何をするか情報を聞き出すためだ
俺だぁ実売はものですの盗賊ではない今なんか人をやっちゃったり
そういうなんか危ないことをしない俺たちスパイはなぜ酸っぱいをするのかその理由は
極秘の情報
手に入れるためそんなのでし距離だとスパイだからね設定上はそんなスパイな俺たちに
必要なのはこちら
トランシーバーと0 d トランシーバー3色セット3人で遊べる遊びじゃね遊びで
やって遊びでやってんじゃないよこっちは仕事でやってんだよ
でこのトランシーバーを使うとなんと端10m まで通信が可能みたいな
を大
大プラズマ3つ出てきましたねとりあえず1回ベンツを入れてみましょう
立ずを通称できるはずです
だってすんだろうピカッ
パルゲーム使おう
すげー普通に伸びてないということは前にスイーツ
本日電源を入っているんでトープボタンを押すってマイクスピーカーに立って喋って
くださいじゃあもうちょっと待ってはちょっとずつぞ
マイはちょっとずっと猫のターーーンッ
知らない音がやべログアウトラン巣鴨で離れていくんで声袋がちょっと聞いてください
行ってきます
あっはい
聞こえてたねまあこれちゃんとできてるんだよかったドンキで買ったからなんかマジ
いかれポンチかと思ったけどちゃんと出来るみたいですね
えって言って今度行くのトランシーバーを大量に買いました
[音楽]
合計21校のトランシーバを準備しましたひとつに3つ入ってその3つしか頼んだら
ヘルツするみたいなのがあってないのかなと思ったんですけど見たところそういう
ヘルペスが設定トップない一緒にこれ時代にもならヘッドずつ周波数を合わせるような
部分がないので多分全部共通で
同じ周波数で音が繋がってるのかなと思ったんですよ
たぶん何も書いてる
皆さんもそうだというとおそらくこのトランシーバ全部繋がっていますたでも黄色て
黄色も繋がってるはずです
ほらあの前黄色のトランシーバーでの失敗を飛ばすなカッティングの中に神ということ
これ全部電源を入れると
なぜだとうるせござるはいはいあーん
[拍手]
ん
糞うぜえこの東京で俺は何をするかというと誰が来てもおかしくないとして何が仕掛け
てあってもおかしくない誰が来てもおかしくないそんな危険だフェア今から俺は部屋中
に登野城せっ
これだけのトランシーバーの量でネットワークを網羅せればこの家中のあらゆる音
あらゆる声を張られる人物の炎とすべてさせることができこれが瞬時に行動することが
できる今から
の21個のもし星いまからほど20いくんただシールを使って俺の部屋の安全の身を
守っ
俺スパイ前で警備の人が結構ん
[拍手]
me
[音楽]
しています
4位
これで折れなきゃが至る所にとらしい[ __ ]
これで私はこの部屋から動かずにすべての指令を出すことができるために選んでみよう
入って言うけども部下をちょっとにつけているので女部屋で床にお互いかとこにいても
会話が出来るような釣果になっております
早速コミュニケーションをとってみましょう
[音楽]
ご乗車会まずは咳き込みますでしょうか
かろうじて聞こえマスター
8誰が別棟を順番に行ってみてください
全く聞こえません
全く聞こえませんだと思う
いうえお
まーすん
号竜にはいい
胸へ
me
dea
car
ana あああっ